[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans un point
de vue l'émission quotidienne d'analysé
surtout deux débats du figaro.fr nous
avons retenu aujourd'hui quatre sujets
dans l'actualité nous reparlerons des
déclarations qui font polémique de
manuel valls e sur l'islam l'ancien
premier ministre par le d'un problème de
l'islam est ce que le débat est bien
posée nous y reviendrons nous
reviendrons également sur le verdict
rendu aujourd'hui par le tribunal pénal
international condamnant à la prison à
vie ratko mladic le chef militaire des
serbes de bosnie l'université était au
menu du conseil des ministres va-t-on
enfin vers une sélection qui ne dirait
pas son nom
ou est ce une réforme en trompe l'oeil
et puis nous parlerons du rôle
déterminant de vladimir poutine dans la
résolution du conflit syrien le numéro
un russe qu'ils recevaient hier à sotchi
bachar el assad avant un sommet
tripartite avec l'iran et la turquie
consacré justement à la syrie ne
traiteront ces quatre sujets avec
elisabeth lévy bonsoir vous êtes
directrice de la rédaction de causeur
vous êtes aussi la coanimatrice de
l'esprit de l'escalier sur radio rcj
avec alain finkielkraut est votre
dernier livre les rien pensant est paru
il ya quelques jours aux éditions du
cerf erwan le nom soir vous êtes
consultant en stratégie maître de
conférences à sciences po
chroniqueur à l'opinion est votre
dernier livre résolument positif
s'appelle la france des opportunités
toutes les bonnes nouvelles qu'on ne
vous dit pas et c'est publié aux belles
lettres bonsoir dionne de mon jour vous
êtes grand reporter au figaro magazine
n'est pas de livre en ce moment
peut-être en cours on va voir et renault
va là ça tombe bien vous êtes employé à
plein temps figure mais je vous le
confirme revenir à vos soir vous êtes le
chroniqueur international du figaro on
retrouve aux analyses chaque mardi dans
notre quotidien préféré est votre
dernier livre qu'elle diplomatie pour la
france prendre les réalités telles
qu'elles sont a été publié comme le
livre d'elisabeth aux éditions du cerf
et cette année nous parlons donc si vous
le voulez bien
des dernières déclarations de manuel
valls concernant l'islam le député de
l'essonne et ancien premier ministre
était hier participé hier à un débat
organisé par le quotidien el país et
voici ce qu'il disait
le voilà alors je vais vous donnez là je
vais vous donner la
la phrase qui était celle de manuel
valls tous les pays souffrent d'une
crise d'identité d'identité culturelle
surgissent dans nos sociétés par exemple
de la société française le problème de
l'islam des musulmans est-ce que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut poser la question
elisabeth lévy on sait bien qu'il ya un
problème de l'islam politique
quand on parle du problème de l'islam du
problème des musulmans est ce qu'on
globalise pas un problème jugé
compliquer le problème c'est qu'on a
l'impression que la discussion le débat
public se déroule dans un commissariat
s'ils voulaient quiconque ne comprends
pas ce cas vous me dire manuel valls vie
sur la planète mars à mon avis il ya un
problème évidemment dans l'islam ce
n'est pas le problème de tout l'islam et
personne ne se livre en réalité à cet
amalgame
ce problème concerne effectivement une
partie des musulmans je ne crois pas
qu'il ait voulu dire autre chose et je
crois quand même qu'il est temps qu'on
puisse dire cela sans que s'ils
voulaient on se met à oui mais vous avez
vous le dire tous les musulmans et puis
si on a vraiment l'impression de parler
sous la menace sous une menace en
réalité pour essayer de comprendre ce
qu'il a voulu dire
on se reconnaît manuel valls il a des
dépôts il est sanguin et colérique mais
à ma connaissance il n'est pas raciste
il n'a pas eu à diriger une commune qui
l'avait d'evry où il des musulmans il a
durant fréquenté donc il ya un problème
dans le discret mais un problème qui
n'est pas d'ailleurs qu'en europe il ya
un problème dans l'islam à peu près
partout donc et les premiers à le dire
d'ailleurs sont les musulmans ou sont
des musulmans eux mêmes
donc oui je crois que si on veut
l'affronter si on veut il faut pouvoir
le dire maintenant ensuite une fois
qu'on a dit ça il faut évidemment faire
des distinctions
mais oui justement revenons sur sur
lefigaro.fr laoufi laden le dis je ne
comprends pas pourquoi valls ne fait pas
la différence entre l'islamisme et
l'islam là on est au coeur du sujet on
est au coeur de ce qu'est une différence
de nature ou 2 degrés alors c'est un
connaisseur de la théologie musulmane
deux musulmanes mais je pense que ce qui
pose problème pour le coup dans
l'expression de manuel valls c'est que
d'une certaine façon il biaise le débat
alors moi je suis d'accord avec qu'ils
avaient très vite on comprend très bien
ce qui veut dire quand il aborde le
sucre quand ils formulent le sujet tu
vois quand on dit le problème de l'islam
saas pour répondre à ça la question
telle qu'il la pose à mon sens n'oblige
entrer dans les questions qui sont
immédiatement est ce que l'islam
comment est ce que l'islam est
compatible avec la république etc etc
or c'est pas effectivement pas le sujet
il ya une différence à faire entre islam
et islamisme
néanmoins je pense que ce que dit manuel
valls là c'est ce que ça me rappelle un
peu le débat qui avait eu il ya fort
longtemps quand lionel jospin faisait
n'ya pas d'insécurité il ya un sentiment
d'insécurité bamba le sentiment
d'insécurité il est là les français
globalement je crois ne font pas la
distinction et ils ont l'impression
qu'il ya un sujet islam qui est posée
dans le débat public
il ya certaines expressions de l'islam
qui sont problématiques mais ces
expressions ne sont pas forcément
assignables si vous voulez sous le nom
d'islamisme ou deux
ou de salafisme il ya des expressions de
l'islam ça bien de l'intérieur de
l'islam ça on peut pas le nier
à l'extérieur et l'esquivé distinguer je
crois à l'islam l'islamisme c'est que
l'islamisme c'est un projet politique et
donc mais ensuite il me semble que le
vrai sujet c'est panne et c'est encore
plus dans les océans encore même dans
l'islam est ce que vous avez des
islamistes qui ont un projet politique
qui n'est pas nécessairement qui est
qu'ils acceptent le débat démocratique
et c'est pas c'est pas nécessairement ça
qu'il faut ce projet qui fait le débat
aujourd'hui au soudan avant d'arriver au
pouvoir fin oui d'accord mais peut-être
est-ce que c'est c'est le terme de
valser gamme il aborde le sujet de front
certes il est quand même réducteur et et
il faut aussi rappeler qu'il ya comme on
l'a dit à l'instant il ya énormément de
musulmans en france qui vivent leur
religion sans que ça pose le moindre
problème mais il à part dont je vais
j'arrête après ce tunnel mais il a un
mérite c'est que y pose quand même le
débat tel que le ressentent je pense une
partie de l'opinion et comme leur sang
l'ensemble des opinions occidentales
il suffit de voir les élections récentes
re qui est dangereux il en fait trop
manuel valls oui il en fait trop et fait
sa pub tout le temps il est comme ces
apprentis jardiniers qui n'est pas
sincère il fait juin je pense que à un
homme politique comme lui qui a si aussi
dramatiquement échoué dans la dernière
élection et dans la primaire etc se dit
comment je peux encore exister et il a
trouvé un filon et le creuse son sillon
de la pas trouvé hier quand même mais en
fait qu'elle pouvait dès lors dans la
laïcité il en parle depuis les premiers
ministres où on les attend talent
charlie hebdo en juin 2015 il fait une
déclaration disant l'islam n'est pas un
problème
parlez à vos à vos à vos images
salafistes montrez leur que vous n'êtes
pas comme eux vous êtes l'immense
majorité du peuple musulman en france
vous avez tout à fait vocation à vous
intégrer
il leur dit ça génial il ya un vrai
verbatim qui est quasiment l'opposé de
ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui donc soit la
parole publique n'a plus aucun poids
soit de l'homme n'étaient que entre à
venir des éléments de langage qui lui
étaient écrits par d'autres personnes
soit il est en train de aujourd'hui de
faire un virage vraiment qui d'ailleurs
rejoint là certains virages de la droite
identitaire mais mais aujourd'hui la
réalité qui avait fait un bien bel
moi je crois pas si ces virages voulais
juste ce qu'ils disaient en octobre 2016
l'islam certes rencontre et pose des
défis considérables à nos sociétés mais
il n'est pas le problème
l'islam est une part indissociable de
nous-mêmes de notre culture est
désormais de nos racines et l'islam de
france comme toutes les religions a
toute sa place en france peut-être qu'il
a changé d'avis en fait non peut-être
qu'il a changé d'avis en tout cas il est
parlé en espagnol je crois dans cette
interview d'aujourd'hui à el país et
lui-même est absolument on peut pas
soupçonner qu'il ait fait une erreur de
formulation
il a été dans des fonctions qui lui qui
rendent sa parole quand même pesant 2
c'est à dire qu'il sait exactement ce
qu'il dit donc qui sait pas anodin il a
pas il n'a pas fait une maladresse
volontaires ils avaient vraiment envie
de dire ça je pense qu'il relève vous
avez très bien fait les usages de ce
qu'ils voulaient dire moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il a changé d'avis parce
que c'est important politiquement de
changer d'avis d'être à gauche et de
dire ce qui ne masque pas bon vous
pensez qu'un gauche c'est opportun de
dire ça mais je pense que c'est un oscar
et les moyens il ouvre une nouvelle
porte est dedans
excusez moi c'est pas la voie la plus
facile à gauche c'est certainement pas
de s'attaquer aux seconds magna qui sont
donnés il devait selon mediapart
il cédera justement sur médiapart dont
jeu juste ce mot de moi ce que vous
dites oui c'est tout ça est très
contrôlée moi ce que je vois c'est que
manuel valls est complètement sanguins
et que par exemple dans la terre
mediapart où se trouvait finalement la
défense détruits plenel avait été
tellement ridicule que dans le fond il
était plutôt affaibli et sa position
était affaiblie et que fait valls il dit
il faut lui faire rendre gorge aux
collections du débat que justement on va
la regarder cette fois ci non messier
est ce que est ce qu'il est possible
qu'on nous le qu'on le voit alors on
regarde manuel valls solange pas ici se
souviennent de la cli cité un deal à
deal était culturel pour qui la
globalisation aille la crise politique à
haïti à l'aise à gauche française ahmad
al islam tergat sur le cash nos shows
très chaud moche ça c'était les
déclarations de manuel valls hier et
voici sa déclaration du 15 novembre dont
sur rmc dont elisabeth lévy parle est un
instant la phrase de 2016 la mienne
reste mon histoire sur les gauches
irréconciliables wii la wii ce sont des
gens dangereux ce qui prononce ses
phrases qui les écrit parce qu'il y en a
qui les entendent y en a qui disent
entendre ses phrases je veux qu'ils
reculent
je veux qu'il rende gorge je veux qu'il
soit écarté du débat public non pas par
l'interdiction
c'est pas le sujet qu'elle rende gorge
qu'il perde qu'il perde ce combat et
cette guerre que limonaire de leur
crédit mais cette guerre d'idées
cette bataille d'idées mais celle là que
nous nous la menons pour la république
et je l'amène pour les musulmans de
france parce que c'est nous qui les
protège on s'est pas monsieur plenel et
ses sbires voit la manière assez s'est
interrogé sur les islamo gauchiste
étaient eux qui voulaient faire rendre
gorge
on l'avait compris renaud girard moi je
voudrais donner un
témoignage de géopoliticien parce que je
suis pas les petites phrases au jour le
jour et en tout cas pas celle de trà
vinh valls qui effectivement un
politicien de deuxième catégorie en
france n'a pas été sélectionné par la
primaire du parti socialiste qui
lui-même n'est jamais vraiment quitté la
catégorie et et qui voit là et qui s'est
fait élire je crois que tout à fait de
justesse à la députation parce qu'il
avait eu le l'ancien d'emmanuel macron
non la question de l'islam
elle se pose bien sûr là se pose dans le
monde parce que c'est une religion qui
n'a pas fait sa réforme ou jeu direct
qui a fait sa réforme dans le mauvais
sens le christianisme a fait sa réforme
sas a appelé la réforme d'ailleurs et
ensuite j'ai eu la contre-réforme
quelques une réforme c'est à dire que
l'église catholique par exemple elle
s'est excusée d'avoir fait des ennuis à
galilée pour avoir dit la vérité
et aujourd'hui voilà et bien sûr elle
c'est au qg s'est excusé aussi auprès
des juifs d'avoir dans le catéchisme
parler du peuple déicide alors qu'il
s'agissait seulement du sanhédrin de
jérusalem qui condamner jésus avec
l'aide de ponce pilate
non il ya un problème c'est
qu'effectivement vous cette réforme a eu
lieu et cette réforme a et deux dans le
sens de la régression c'est le salafiste
c'est la réforme introduite par hassan
abed al banna en 1928 en égypte le père
des frères musulmans
effectivement la ligue l'idéologie des
frères musulmans pose un problème et je
pense personnellement qu un djihadiste
qui commet des attentats est un frère
musulman qui va jusqu'au bout alors les
racines de la france non je ne pense pas
du tout on a dit quelque part que
l'islam fasse partie des racines
historiques hamas en 2007 je pense
qu'ils se trompent alors qu'il faudrait
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'ils étudient
l'histoire de france dont il ya des
racines
et des racines de la france qui sont des
racines gréco latine qui sont des
racines judéo chrétiennes et qui sont
des racines des lumières ça c'est le
socle intellectuel de la france
et puis il ya une colonisation et puis
il ya un rapport affectivement et des
musulmans qui ont souhaité immigrés en
france une des relations il ya eu il ya
eu aussi des mouvements qui ont souhaité
la dépendance de la france pour vivre
leur religion comme ils ne voulaient
comme en algérie par exemple
et puis voilà et met dans la tradition
française de choses qui sont très
importantes qui sont la séparation du
politique et du religieux et ça remonte
au christianisme c'est à dire la parole
du christ de rendez à césar ce qui
appartient à césar est quelque chose qui
est très important si dans notre
histoire politique c'est l'égalité des
femmes et des hommes
l'islam n'y est pas encore certains
musulmans dans l'histoire ont voulu
faire des réformes je pense à moi mais
d'abdou à la fin du 19e siècle
peut-être que ce prince saoudien veut
vraiment faire des formes on n'en sait
rien une belle c'est ce qu'il sait ce
qu'il raconte mais nous ne pouvons pas
transiger sur ses valeurs qui sont très
importantes et nous avons un petit
problème effectivement aujourd'hui avec
la religion des gens que j'avais posé
dire la question à erdogan président
turc ans il était venu il ya trois ans à
paris et une réunion jeudi monsieur le
président est ce que vous seriez
favorable à une réforme de l'islam et il
m'avait répondu non chers amis l'islam
n'a pas besoin de la moindre
je pense qu'ils se trompaient c'est le
leader de la turquie des frères
musulmans
je pense qu'ils se trompaient et je
pense que la voie dans laquelle il
emmène la turquie avec son parti
islamiste est une mauvaise voie et une
voix qui va d'ailleurs la coupe la coupe
et la dureté de la vie modernité et de
relations de bon voisinage ce que juste
pour aller pour confirmer en fait ce que
dira nous mais ce qu'on voit en fait
c'est que l'islam est minoritaire
évidemment aussi voulait donner
ce ne sont pas les mieux les individus
se sont pas les musulmans qui posent
problème comme un 8-2 qu'al islam est
minoritaire
il est bien obligé de se conformer aux
valeurs disons de la société d'accueil
le problème c'est qu'il est majoritaire
même sur un petit territoire
c'est il a beaucoup de problèmes avec le
pluralisme
or comme vient de le dire renault c'est
quand même un peu le coeur de notre
identité
et puis juste il a rappelé cette
déclaration la cette idée si vous voulez
que la france a des racines musulmanes
je vous rappelle qu'on n'a pas réussi à
inscrire dans la défendre constitution
européenne que l'europe avait des
racines chrétiennes et en évidence qui
évidemment une évidence qui est
totalement absurde et donc en plus de
tout ce qui nous empêche à mon avis de
contraindre un peu l'islam à sa culture
et comme on l'a fait quand même avec les
catholiques à la dure et comme on l'a
fait un peu avec les juifs parce que
napoléon leur a quand même posé des
conditions
ce qui ne nous empêche c'est notre
espèce de repentance permanente
je veux dire on se bat la coulpe en
perdons pas notre call pardon en
permanence
est-ce que de dire qu'ils sont un
problème et un est un moyen les
accompagner vers cette réforme est
nécessaire dont l'écouté ya un truc est
pas un moyen c'est de les câliner en
permanent et très bien conclu à un moyen
oui des mots dire qu'il ya un problème
dans l'islam alors il faut peut-être pas
dire 2 il faut le dire il faut dire
maintenant que les musulmans doivent
prendre en main ce problème dans l'islam
est arrêté si vous voulez de considérer
que l'islamophobie est un problème plus
grave que la maladie de l'islam comme
l'avait appelée abdelwahab meddeb
il faut le dire parce que trente ans de
ce que de ce qu'on a fait pendant trente
ans c'est justement pas vouloir leur
dire c'est la tension on ne va pas
d'excès attention nous sommes d'abord
l'ouverture avant d'être quoi que ce
soit nous sommes une ouverture et nous
allons nous oublier pour vous accueillir
et bien non il faut se respecter les
gens ça peut leur dire pour devenir
français pour habiter en france pour
habiter en europe pour être des citoyens
à part entière
il y a je veux dire des concessions à
terre il ya des choses que vous devez
abandonner cette règle
en fait dans le monde de l'histoire et
moi-même bin salman le nouveau prince
oui il a dit c'est à dire que à partir
de 79
il faut rappeler aux auditeurs qui est
une attaque de la mecque qui a été réglé
que avec l'aide de la gendarmerie
française et après une sorte de deal a
été passé entre la monarchie saoudienne
et les islamistes sunnites dans dix ans
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez à
l'extérieur propager l'islam le plus
puritain le plus dur à l'extérieur du
moment que vous ne mettez pas en cause
la dynastie saoudienne cet impact
terrible
mb s est dit que c'était une erreur une
erreur qu'ils imputaient la révolution
islamique qui se passait en même temps
dans l'iran chiite
enfin peu importe c'était une erreur et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut à tout prix
revenir à une religion qu'ils soient en
fait qu'ils reviennent dans le hall dans
le secteur privé j'ai interviewé pour le
crime le cigare ont récemment le
président égyptien qui est un homme
pieux et ce président est sérieuse et
qu'il fallait séparer le politique du
religieux et c'est évident il y a
quelques semaines dans le figaro fr
je partage en partie l'analyse
d'elizabeth may avec une union salaire
je ne suis pas convaincu que vous
discutez sur les territoires où l'islam
est majoritaire à air comprimé petit
territoire en france il y ait une fin
l'islam impose une absence de pluralisme
il ya certaines jour lieu ou non mais là
pour le coup je sus que les venir j
habite donc je vois très bien de quoi il
peut s'agir mais je crois pas que soit
l'élu la majorité des musulmans de ces
quartiers là c'est une minorité très
agissante qui effectivement impose sa
loi et fait peur en premier lieu aux
musulmans qui implique qu'ils habitent
dans ces quartiers bien sûr on en vient
aligner sur celles où mon père habite
les musulmans enquiquine des musulmanes
surtout tout à fait crédible mais après
là pour venir sur valseuses et ce alors
moi je veux pas l'impression valls il
utilise l'actualité il est au coeur de
l'actualité il aa c'est un sujet qu'il a
investi depuis longtemps là je me trompe
peut-être mais le sentiment que j'ai
c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui quand il
était premier ministre avait envie de
porter ces sujets je n'ai entendu
récemment je me trompe pas dire que ça
l'avait beaucoup tout ça l'avait
beaucoup affecté que sa femme on avait
été beaucoup victimes de toutes ces
toutes les attaques antisémites et je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui a envie de dire haut et fort
on met le holà ça suffit alors peut-être
qu'il exprime de manière brutale mais je
crois pas qu'ils ont je pense qu'il est
assez sincère concédé le match d'hier on
sait qu il pouvait pas dire quand il
était au ps dès qu'il a bon c'est un
pied sur un orteil sur ce genre de sujet
il son pm est déchiré nous c'est un
phénomène très graves des maux
l'antisémitisme quoi et qu'on s'en était
débarrassé avec la libération de la
france en 1944 avait déjà suffisamment
souffert ça n'est pas que de la crise
est là et il est revenu pardon on était
débarrassé ensuite la france l'avait
déshonoré en cas d'occupation on a eu
après un dirigeant la france qui était
juif qui s'appelait mendès-france qui à
dire plus ou bien érigé donc le peuple
était prêt il y aurait pu
d'antisémitisme en france est d'avoir un
retour si vous voulez d'avoir à propos
de gaza qui n'a rien à voir avec la
situation française avoir eu des
manifestations après à paris où des gens
criaient mort aux juifs
c'est une régression considérable mais
notre pays est là là dessus je considère
comme vous que
manuel valls a raison d'enfoncer le clou
merci qui monte assure que quand il
était premier ministre il est pris
suffisamment de mesures efficaces seront
sur ce phénomène doit l'être at il
retrouvé une liberté de parole qu'il
n'avait pas je vous propose de nous
donner votre avis sur le verdict rendu
ce matin par le tribunal pénal
international condamnant à la réclusion
à perpétuité
ratko mladic qui était le chef militaire
des serbes de bosnie condamné bien sûr
pour les actes commis pendant cette
guerre et notamment le massacre de
srebrenica
écoutez ce que disait le procureur du
tribunal pénal international pour la
yougoslavie serge brammertz était ce
matin à nay dimanche c'est une décision
c'est un jugement qui était tardif est
ce que c'est parce qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement compte tenu de la
complexité du dossier ou est ce que
c'est la limite de cette juridiction
internationale
on est presque 25 ans après les faits
après les faits une génération
à mon avis c'est plus une victoire deux
c'est plus une justice de la victoire
qu'une victoire d'injustice dire qu'en
fait c'est chaud les vainqueurs qui
écrivent l'histoire
donc en fait là les serbes depuis 25 ans
sont devant ce tribunal de façon
objectivement massive par rapport aux
bosniaques aux croates on a condamné oui
mais en fait vous l'argile
malheureusement que non pas en 2000 il
ya effectivement bien terminer ensuite
enfin ça donc je trouve que d'hab
d'abord je trouve que la serbie la pop
on prend à bien a bien vécu ce temps du
tribunal le temps du procès et ils ont
emporté des condamnations je ne juge pas
là dit que parce que je pense qu à 425
personnes à plein temps dans ce tribunal
depuis 25 ans ça coûte une fortune 90
millions par an d'euros en budget donc
je pense qu'ils ont fait une enquête
sérieuse et que ce verdict est
absolument
voilà imparable mais je dois dire que ce
que je salue dans ce d'abord la première
chose qui me gêne c'est que cet homme
est très affaibli il et il a eu trois
avc il est c'est quand même un vieux
monsieur qu'on condamne à perpétuité je
trouve que humainement moi c'est ça me
choque toujours qu'un tout vieux tout
vieux tout mais vous savez peut-être que
moi donc c'est pour les vivants c'est
pour ce qu'elles resteront après que
cette justice va avoir du sens et va
féconder quelque chose de bien et je
trouve que ce qui est bien c'est que
dans une guerre civile
toutes les fois où il ya une culture de
l'impunité elle a été terrible je pense
au liban je pense au procès hariri
je pense à toutes ces toutes ces guerres
où tout c'est toutes ces guerres qui ont
laissé derrière elles une espèce d'entre
d'entre mais melman de situation dont on
ne sait pas qui est coupable qui n'est
pas coupable on laisse les choses et al
finalement produisent toujours des
catastrophes à moyen terme et à long
terme céder petite grenade d'ebooks
dégoupiller partout donc je salue le
fait que dans une guerre civile ya eu un
procès et que voilà celui ci voilà se
termine comme ça avant d'agir à vous
partager ce point de vue il ya une
justice à deux vitesses c'est à dire que
les serbes ont davantage été condamné
que les deux chiens que les albums que
ça va je rappelle juste que vous avez
couvert sur les couvertes ou secours le
diront que des traits même crise ouverte
c'est grâce à renaud girard quand j'ai
compris quelque chose
voilà qu'on aille dire c'est que vous
avez effectivement couvert l'intégralité
de ce conflit alors il ya deux choses
premièrement
le général mladic est tout à fait
responsable du massacre de srebrenica où
aucun doute il est entré dans l'enclavé
qui était protégé par les nations unies
le 11 juillet 1995 et il est ses troupes
ont massacré dans les deux semaines qui
suivaient et j'ai même mois interrogé
plus tard en secret un des massacreurs
massacre et 7000 hommes et garçons dont
ils sont pas attaqués à la population
féminine nation masculine de cette
enclave à ce que mes d'homos des civils
civils au lieu de les faire partir ils
pouvaient faire partir les hommes et les
femmes en même temps vers tous à des
femmes ont raison les enfants ont été
dirigées les vieillards ont été rédigées
sur une zone musulmane et donc c'est
très bien qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
condamnés
on aurait aimé que ce soit plutôt puis
il a pu se cacher on aurait aimé que que
voilà qu'ils soient en meilleur état
mais il mérite tout à fait sa
condamnation à perpétuité c'est tout à
fait certain en revanche on regrette que
ce tribunal sur l'ex yougoslavie et pas
effectivement ait eu la main lourde
uniquement vers en les garder c'est
remet donc ça fait justice de vainqueur
puisque finalement ce sont des serbes
ont perdu cette bière civile à burgos la
vie à la fin et on regrette par exemple
que au kosovo donc c'est cette une
guerre de l'otan n'est ce pas en 1999
pour obliger la serbie a lâché sa
province du kosovo à l'ofce caennaise de
l'armée de libération des albanais qui
sont la majorité de la population de
cette province serbe du kosovo
il ya eu deux mille victimes 2000
vieillard 2000 serbes civils qui ont été
massacrés par lou checa ou enfin en tout
cas en albanie et pas un seul dirigeant
de lucetta qui se retrouvent d'ailleurs
à des risées voit le kosovo qui
t'arrange comme un état indépendant par
retourner damnation
pas reconnu par tout le monde mais qui
est reconnu par la france on peut
regretter effectivement que qu' il ya eu
une impunité et de même on peut
regretter aussi que l'ancien commandant
de srebrenica mais qui n'était pas là au
moment du massacre parce qu'il avait été
retiré parce qu'en fait ils s'appellent
devait donner aux serbes dans les quatre
ans fait une raison pour massacrer 7000
hommes voilà lui-même a été élargie
alors qu'il est coupable d'un petit
massage d'un petit massaka kravitz salle
7 janvier 1993 ou une jour de noël nuit
de noël les bosses et les musulmans de
srebrenica était allé faire un raid ou
avec les habitués ne centaines de civils
serbes dans ce village c'est pas une
raison deux ans et demi après pour faire
une vengeance aussi énorme et tué sept
mille personnes dans les bastions
elisabeth les mains je voulais juste
dire en plus que sur l'ensemble de la
guerre moi j'ai été très frappée
aujourd'hui en entendant les
commentaires de voir que vingt ans après
c'est vous dire on avait toujours une
vision extrêmement émotionnelles
simplement émotionnel et manichéen avec
c'est à dire les gens les maisons
et je me rappelle la sphère de
srebrenica il y avait quand même une
chose c'est pourquoi pourquoi il est des
mots vite chez at il ordonné à son armée
pourquoi si leur donner un assez
rohfritsch au deuxième quart mais
c'était de le quitter de quitter la
ville c'est-à-dire de livres et on
savait très bien que l'onu resterait
larmes au pied ou dix on pouvait le
craindre
c'est grave c'est très grave c'est là
que le bât qui le bat s'il est très
grave c'est vrai qu'il ya des billets
des responsables bataillon de le nul est
très parlant d bataillon de
parachutistes auprès des juges et on l'a
on disait la hollande a dû verser
effectivement des compositions à l'agro
familles musulmanes matériel à accepter
mais il est tout à fait honteux que le
bataillon de parachutistes salut mon
bataillon de parachutistes hollandais
qui devait au titre de l'article 7 de la
charte des nations unies s'est dit qu'il
devait engager soient pas intervenues
les suivantes et là ça ne soit pas battu
je n'ai pas de tirer un coup de feu ne
sais pas quoi à quoi servent à quoi
servait terminer votre intervention et
ensuite on écoutera verve en iran ce qui
m'a frappé moi c'est quand même d'être
responsable si on ne peut pas s'empêcher
quand même de penser d'ailleurs que
illégaux beach a délibérément sacrifiés
srebrenica pour faire basculer la guerre
il ya eu quand même d'autres cas où
l'équipe était quand même d'origine mise
en regard d'un tout ça n'a jamais été
dans le fond il n'y a pas un jugement
politique aussi à porter sur un mégot
vise qui était mort l'amour ensuite bien
sûr que ça ne justifie en rien je suis
tout à fait d'accord
il n'empêche que dans une guerre quand
tu abandonnes t sybille en gros face à
une armée dont on sait qu'elle n'est pas
particulièrement porté sur les droits de
l'homme et la dream le salon a pour sa
part offert par celle là on ne va pas
refaire jean vigo ville je pense que
c'est l'asie three des responsables du
massacre
il a été condamné et c'est une essais no
mercy on aimerait que les massacreurs au
kosovo soit aux condamnés de la même
façon air maintenant alors je te ment
pas refaire le procès
moi je crois que ce qui m intéresse en
tout cas l'annoncé aujourd'hui c'est le
fait qu'on a réussi qu'on ait réussi ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure à sortir par
le droit en un conflit à sortir avec la
mise en place d'un système judiciaire
spécifique et c'est extrêmement
intéressant que ça allait fonctionner je
pense que toutefois il y avait une seule
ni par le droit on en est sorti voilà
neuf ans par les armes
attendez que je fais mais est-ce que ce
que pour autant je pense pas que
contrairement à d'autres que ça veut
dire que le droit est systématiquement
la bonne solution et qu'il faut par
exemple le défendre la cour pénale
internationale qui pour lui est un outil
est un autre sujet mais qui découlent de
ces tribunaux la politique aussi est une
manière de sortir des conflits et ce
n'est pas systématiquement la solution
judiciaire qui prévaut merdeux girard
est d'aider des jugements comme celui ci
ne va pas inciter tous les dictateurs du
monde à rester au pouvoir coûte que
coûte
de crainte d'être jugée par une cour
internationale pour peu qu'ils aient
commis quelques exactions et donc et
donc il ne passe jamais le pouvoir qu'il
faut faire effectivement très attention
aux il faut en tout cas montré qu'on est
capable de donner des immunités et là
vous faites allusion à quelque chose
d'autre très précis c'est effectivement
l'immunité qui avait donné
jacques chirac lorsque mladic avait
libéré les pilotes français qui étaient
tombés en bombardant les serbes de les
serbes de bosnie et qui était prisée qui
étaient prisonniers des serbes mais il
ya eu ensuite ça se passait en joie mais
il ya eu ensuite un événement encore
plus importante qui quand même
et quand même surtout à la fin de la
guerre ce matin de srebrenica
je pense que je pense que là il ya quand
même c'est comme à
sacs de tels d'une telle étendue qu'il
était nécessaire de condamner l'a dit et
il ya une bonne chose qu'à inventer à ce
moment là le tribunal international
c'est qu'il a dit qu'ils avaient une
liste casser ça c'était une très bonne
idée qu'ils ont eue c'est à dire qu'il y
avait une liste ce qu'elle donc tous les
types qui avait tué si vous voulez de
tous les coins avait très peur n'osais
plus voyager ne sait plus aller claquer
leur argent à amsterdam pour vous ou en
allemagne ou en france espèrent ils
avaient très peur donc ça c'était une
motocycliste clandestine des criminels
de guerre recherchés mais je suis aussi
favorable
effectivement aux immunités qui peuvent
qui peuvent effectivement arrêté arrêter
les guerres et par exemple ou favoriser
la transition démocratique favoriser et
je trouve qu'on a eu tort
nous français lorsqu'en mars 2010 où
douze les russes par le biais de
l'ambassadeur conseil de sécurité nous
ont proposé de commencer à discuter
d'une transition en syrie et donc de
faire partir petit à petit avec les
honneurs bachar al assad et nous avons
nous nous avons refusé nous avons encore
parce qu'on a dit ah bah de toute façon
il va tomber nourrira semaine ça y est
ça voilà il est toujours là et nous
allons revenir d'ailleurs dans sa bachar
al assad mais non mais dans quelques
minutes pas avant d'être revenu à paris
pour parler de la réforme des
universités at on mis en place oui ou
non une forme de sélection à l'entrée à
l'université et bien je vous propose
d'écouter tout de suite frédéric vidal
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
c'était ce matin sur europe 1 je suis
pas certain que vous ayez la réponse à
la question il faut que vouloir écouter
mais je vous laisse juge élèves n'aura
pas toujours le dernier mot les lèvres à
tchô le dernier mot dans le choix de sa
filière par contre il devrait faire
confiance à ces enseignants pour le
chemin et le parcours à emprunter pour
aller vers le diplôme qu'ils souhaitent
obtenir et donc dans certains cas
l'université va choisir ses étudiants
alors le seul cas
c'est éventuellement si malgré le nombre
de places que nous allons ouvrir dans
les établissements et malgré les
différents dispositifs qui vont être mis
en place pour accueillir les étudiants
dans les filières en tension c'est le
seul cas revenons en sélection ou pas
sélection en fait elle dit il y aura pas
d'élection sauf dans les cas où il y en
aura oui d'ailleurs la sélection dans
les cas où si j'aime il a compris
certaines filières sont tellement il ya
tellement de demandes que les
établissements les universités pourront
choisir c'est un don le libéral que vous
êtes à ce que c'est une bonne réforme ce
qui se prépare c mu probablement mieux
cap et bep qui était inquiété une
catastrophe tout le monde s'accorde est
ce que c'est mais c'est comme souvent
avec ce gouvernement un petit pas un
petit pas et on en franchit pas on ne
sait pas il ne s'est pas une grande
réforme la réforme
on est quand même dans un contexte
perdons deux qui est censé être celui de
l'autonomie des universités la réforme
c'est le jour on laissera l'université
d'orléans celle de marseille ou celle de
rennes dira voilà quels sont les
critères pour choisir mes étudiants est
comme ça quand on osera dire qu'on
n'osera dire que soient tous les
bacheliers ne doivent pas accéder à
l'université soit qui ne doit pas y
avoir qu il doit y avoir 60 % de
réussite au bac nous servant d' % de
réussite au bac
la vraie réforme on la fera mais quand
on entend hall après quand on arrivera
vraiment à ça c'est à dire mais non mais
ce qui le fera qu'en fait c'est que le
réel vous voyez vous avez tous on a tous
des jeunes autour de nous donc dans la
réalité des bonnes les bonnes formations
sont déjà toutes sélective et ils le
savent très bien et donc un espace de
combat sur les mots et quand j'entends
les les étudiants de l'unef qui
d'ailleurs sont passés en deuxième ce
qui est quand même pas anodin comme
nouvelle non c'est vrai c'est plus le
c'est plus le premier syndicat étudiant
quand je les entends d'y goûter sur leur
truc
je dois avoir la place que je veux quand
je veux c'est à dire entre complètement
irréaliste parce que ça fait des
formations poubelle rires je me dis bon
et encore du temps que ça va pas changer
pour nous mais ça va changer
fondamentalement le système français où
ils fois il faut pour réussir à avoir un
cdi et que le seuil étant tellement
plein de contraintes
on sélectionne les meilleurs étudiants à
l'entrée sont arrachées travail qui eux
mêmes sont ceux qu'ont choisi les
meilleures écoles qui ont été choisis
les meilleurs établissements
vous avez un phénomène de sélection qui
commence à l'école primaire qui se font
jusqu'au m'insulte rails et qui existe
aujourd'hui et que tout le monde connaît
cette réforme va rien changer
les meilleurs de ligue 1 non mais moi je
suis pro je vous dis pas que c'est
scandaleux je vous dis juste que cette
réforme ne change rien et qu'aujourd'hui
on est déjà dans le système de sélection
qui ne le dit pas et ceux qui ne vont
pas dans les filières sélectives sont
restés laissé sur le côté
ce qui est dommage c'est que le
gouvernement n'aille pas jusqu'à bien
sûr non mais attendez il faut dire les
choses de manières car et bien sûr que
l'université ne doit pas être une
garderie des et déjà et bien sûr que
l'école primaire doit apprendre à lire
compter est calculé et pas de baies de
goji
voilà voilà et que effectivement les
mêmes ce mode éducation nationale jette
encore plus réactionnaires vous croyez
je n'aime pas ce mot d'éducation
nationale je préfère le mot
d'instruction publique qu'on avait
autrefois sous jules ferry parce que
l'éducation c'est le parent qui éduquent
leurs enfants
il s'agit d'instruire quant à
l'université bien sûr qu'il faut une
sélection à l'entrée de l'université
bien sûr ce n'est pas une garderie on
n'a pas des droits à entrer à
l'université il faut un niveau comme
comme d'ailleurs dans toutes les
universités du monde y a qu'en france où
on a ce système débile de garderie et je
regrette que que ce ministre qui est un
bon ministre blanc qu'erdf dire les gens
n'est donc pas ce qu'il veut qu'on
apprenne justement à lire à écrire et à
compter
je regrette c'est pour sa part les
crédits à vue je regrette que que la
réforme n'aille pas jusqu'au bout
sarkozy nous avait promis l'epani
sarkozy les avait promis une autonomie
de l'université comme toujours avec le
sarkozy comme nous en faire un cas je
m'appelle jusqu'au bout et on n'a pas eu
la vraie autonomie de la voix haute
devant c'est la liberté de l'université
a recruté qu'elle veut et même ce n'est
donc pas rire étude qui donne la parole
à des visiteurs est payante avec des
prêts avec des prêts pour les étudiants
avec une wasla non seulement en payant
mais en plus sélectifs alors
effectivement on en est loin c'est
peut-être pour ça cher jean baptiste
émergence du figaro.fr qui nous avait
rejoint c'est peut-être pour ça parce
que c'est pas la révolution du siècle
finalement les réseaux sociaux sont
relativement serein voire même
pas passionné par ce sujet il ya eu un
million à part dont un millier à
milliers tweet cet après midi n'ont pas
20 millions d'étudiants mais on a parlé
un petit peu plus tard à milliers de
tweets aujourd'hui donc on rit c'est
assez peu beaucoup de photos des
manifestations dans paris notamment sur
la place de la république et la place de
la bastille quelques manifestations à
moi j'ai d'abord voulu essayer de
trouver quelques chiffres je suis allé
sur le site du ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur est en fait
c'est une page 404 qui nous donne assez
rapidement les statistiques analyse donc
pas grand chose à voir donc je suis allé
chercher un petit peu plus loin je suis
allé voir le s
guillaume le sdis la fameuse sous
direction des systèmes d'information des
études statistiques et effectivement
quand on regarde le graphique
effectivement il est un peu trop petit
c'est un petit graphique pour des grands
chiffres où l'on nous explique qu'il ya
environ 1 million 600 mille étudiants
pour la dernière rentrée et ça augmente
de 100 mille tous les ans donc
effectivement le chiffre c'est
l'embouteillage
c'est l'embouteillage lire le test ce
sont des chiffres groupe f c'est à dire
on n'a pas ou man is y est nous avons
justement on n'a pas la possibilité on
n'a pas d'abord ni la capacité ni
peut-être probablement les besoins de
forme et si voulez autant des mid et des
centaines de milliers devant en tout en
tous les cas si on arrivait à les amener
tous à l'excellence très bien mais comme
l'a dit renaud on est dans des dans des
garderies tout simplement parce qu'à une
espèce de deux totems il faut avoir un
second à l'université comment jeune
fille qui n'ont absolument pas envie
d'étudier de favori sur dénis renault
les internautes sont d'accord mais là on
a parlé d'apb qui est écrit est très
critiqué hier le ministère s'est fendu
d'un tweet très heureux effet se
félicitant d'avoir réussi à trouver un
nouveau nom qui s'appelle parcours super
bon c'est bien mais on y avait vingt
mille personnes qui ont voté donc sur
nos 1 million 600 mille étudiants c'est
pas génial mais je suis allé voir si
quelques internautes donc nous avons
félix sceptiques qui est très sceptique
qui dit que le problème de la sélection
à l'université c'est que ça ne diminue
pas les bacheliers donc c'est exactement
ce dont parlait tout à l'heure il faut
développer les autres formations que
l'université proposer des filières
intéressante aux étudiants restés sur le
carreau
effectivement il ya un problème
d'orientation et c'est ça que les
internautes veulent expliqué thibault
dit à peu près la même chose et lui
ajoute les problèmes d'inégalité dans
les universités autant de traitements
que d'orientation et enfin l'insoumise
danielle simonnet que vous devez
connaître qui est qui a voulu être élue
à paris ajoute donnant les moyens à
l'université que contribuer à la
réussite de tous
al'inverse
le gouvernement casse l'université par
la baisse des moyens et instaure la
sélection donc des problèmes de moyens
et d'orientation plus qu'un problème
c'est qu'un fantasme de croire ça des
landes avait cette expression l'excès
c'est à dire de dire l'excellence pour
tous est un fantasme absurde
l'aristocratie merci bord avec s'est
lentement c'était tout mais vous allez
voir on essaye de montrer craignent eux
pour une fois qu'on essaye de réformer
ce gros mach à un reer et foreman je
dirais enfin il ya quelque chose qui se
passe alors 25 % des étudiants qui
rentre à l'université ont leur licence
en trois ans mais 75% il échoue
lamentablement
c'est l'hécatombe donc il faut régler le
problème cette même ministre qui ce
matin n'était pas complètement
pertinente semble-t-il a quand même
promis 950 millions d'euros sur cinq ans
pour réformer l'université ben écoutez
je voudrais je me sens nous c'est une
cote mal taillée aujourd'hui mais on va
voir d'abord un lieu chez deux mois pour
l'université où j'ai déjà bien l'esprit
des profs de lycée pour leur demander de
rendre des avis de former les élèves de
donner un avis sur est-ce que cet élève
est capable de rentrer dans cette
filière c'est déjà très bien pourvu que
les choses soient coordonnées que ce
soit via des mails pour moi je suis
contente de voir que on essaye oui mais
connaissait même pas une question d'état
d'esprit qui n'arrivent pas à changer
complètement on n'est pas tous en
intensité
cette idée qu'on a tous droit à un jeu
je précise que les jeunes sont assez
d'accord avec vous puisque selon un
sondage récent 61% d'entre eux sont
favorables à une sélection sur dossier à
l'entrée de l'université sans doute
parce que pour la majorité d'entre eux
ils savent bien que tu ne peux pas
réussir mes héros se fait qu'on n'avait
rien il n'ya rien n'a été fait dans les
dernières années la diversité c'était
quand même un passé hélas probablement
la seule chose que le fait mais ce
mélange de poule mardi un pas mais juste
cela pourrait passer au classement
les verts jusqu'au bout la sélection ne
va rien changer aux problèmes de
l'enseignement supérieur français
pourquoi pas ce que c'est exactement ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure il faut
changer le bac il faut un système de
fautes d'apprentissage et de formation
et de formation et doute de formation
universitaire qui soit aussi bon si vous
voulez c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde se
précipite à l'université 1 c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas de place dans les grandes
écoles et deux c'est parce que personne
ne veut aller dans l'âme dans
l'apprentissage formation
professionnelle qui sont considérés en
france comme des voies de garage vous
avez un une opr un auteur suisse
françois garçon qui a écrit un excellent
l'islam d'apprentissage suisse qui
explique qu'ils aient une apprentie 6 10
et surtout il vit en suisse
oui je viens c'est bien l'idée en suisse
notre gouvernement nous dit fait
l'apprentissage fait il faut que vos
enfants face à l'apprentissage et tout
le monde les croit à ce que la moitié du
gouvernement est issu de l'apprentissage
en france vous avez des énarques des
polytechniciens qui vous dit fait
l'apprentissage regarder mes enfants
vont à normal vont ainsi on m'a demandé
c'est que sur ce plateau parce que sinon
renaud girard qu est ce qui me dérange
en alu phares malien non plus grave et
pas des rares manière en plus je vous
propose de parler d'un dernier sujet
vladimir poutine qui ne gâche pas son
plaisir c'est lui le grand gagnant du
conflit syrien il recevait hier à sotchi
le président syrien bachar el assad
avant l'organisation d'un sommet
tripartite avec l'iran et la turquie
concernant ce dossier est bien le moins
qu'on puisse dire est que le numéro un
russe considère clairement que c'est lui
qui a gagné
regardez
c'était bizarre c'est la douce ça me
faisait chier vraiment pas statu quo
quand celle ci est à banias plus tôt la
tchéquie et chubu d'autres magnifiques
trouvailles éclatent quand je te prends
bien huilée nabli jeunes et au masters
qui est fier du retour tu sais ça quand
vladimir par les militaires 7e se
tiennent au garde à vous renaud girard
bon il ya un gagnant du conflit syrien
c'est poutine
oui très calmes ans parce que
effectivement il est il et il est
intervenu en septembre 2015 pour en fait
sauvé la syrie de bachar al assad du
militaire il est intervenu militairement
non seulement ça a sauvé la salle ont
donné du moral en fait à l'armée
syrienne aujourd'hui à l'est pas été
repris et est repris par la bcn depuis
un an elle se reconstruit une vitesse
extraordinaire d'ailleurs alep et et
alors et des poutines un doublement
gagner parce que donc son allié syrien
rester au pouvoir
l'état laïc syrien bassiste syrien est
resté ce qu'il est et l'est la russie a
soutenu l'état bassiste c'est-à-dire
laïcs syriens depuis depuis 50 ans et la
deuxième victoire c'est que tous les
autres orientaux tous les pays du moyen
orient 10 à poutine
respect monsieur même ceux qui étaient
le plus opposés au régime de bachar al
assad
je veux parler de la turquie de red cpr
dogan et je veux parler de l'arabie
saoudite le roi d'arabie saoudite est
allé faire une visite
elle est faire une visite à moscou au
tsar poutine alors imaginez c'est c'est
le grand succès diplomatique aux maisons
ayant de la russie est ce le grand échec
de la france
la france qui était la puissance
mandataire savez qui a colonisé la cfa
des puissances mandataires de cire de
1929 146 et qui est pas du tout présente
pourquoi pas ce que nous avons fait
preuve d'irréalisme total dans cette
affaire depuis de 2012
je rappelle vous souvenez ou
on se souvient de laurent fabius qui
refusaient n'a visité à la conférence de
genève sur la syrie l'iran parce que
fabius n'aimait pas les iraniens alors
que la norvège était invité à cette
conférence c'est ce que dit monsieur le
ministre si vous n'invitez pas l'iran
vous ne résoudrez jamais le problème
sérieux car il faut prendre réagir et
qu'elles sont merci renaud chira et
d'ailleurs pierre nous dit sur internet
et la france alors rien par
l'interrogation
son approche est tout à fait d'accord
mais j'ai deux choses sur les russes
parce que les russes ils ont un peu
gagné grâce à leur absence de scrupules
aussi c'est à dire qu'ils font des
choses que nous on peut pas faire quand
ils bombardent pas vrai nous on peut
plus faire la guerre comme ça donc c'est
un peu ça qui leur permet aussi d'y
aller avec leurs grands pieds et de pas
trop s'embarrasser de ce qui se passe en
dessous denis effectivement ils n'ont
pas besoin de se cacher pour parler avec
bachar mais la deuxième chose c'est que
là je pose la question à renault en fait
est ce que les russes ont bien non
pardon non vous donner un point de vue
alors bien sûr pose la question je n'ai
pas la réponse pardon alors je pose la
question à mes camarades
voilà vous est ce que les russes ont
bien analysé les conditions qui ont fait
partir la guerre en syrie et est ce que
c'est bien parce d'accord gagner une
guerre c'est une chose mais est ce que
maintenant bachar va être comme dans un
jardin de roses que finalement il va
revenir au merveilleux statu quo ante et
d'autres il faut la provoquer une guerre
sans fin car vous dit poutine a gagné la
guerre mais c'est des mots mais il ya
trop de morts trop de disparus 65 mille
disparus pour que même les vivants se
dédouaner de leurs responsabilités de
leurs échecs poutine n'a pas gagné cette
guerre à la moyen terme allant des
sentiments comment le syrien va-t-il
accepter de réhabiliter dans son
appartement à côté de son bourreau dans
la rue d'en face à face vers la syrie de
demain n'a rien à voir elle peut pas se
reconstruire
tel quel identique à celle qui était là
il ya cinq ans alors qu'on pouvait
encore arrêtée ce conflit donc l'échec
cuisant la diplomatie française certains
rapports de force dans lequel cucina
excellé en effet parce qu'il n'avait pas
de scrupules on n'est pas dans le monde
des bisounours de l'aide au
développement et tous ces trucs dont on
nous serine tout le temps là on est dans
les dents des gens qui veulent vraiment
aller jusqu'au bout comme vous le disiez
très juste rien au débat utile
depuis les années les turcs noter qu
aujourd'hui pourquoi l'as empire se
retrouvent les soviétiques les perses et
est l'opérateur
enfin on a trois empires iii toi trois
pays qui sont aujourd'hui fondamentaux
pour et qui ont cette ségou de lempire
enfin cette espèce de boue de l' empire
dans la bouche quoi qu'il arrive qu'ils
négocient qui essaient de vaguement
concevoir une paix mais je peux vous
dire que la population syrienne à mon
avis c'est pas demain la paix il ya en
elle une rancoeur immense de voir que
bachar el-assad se maintenir au pouvoir
coûte que coûte
en ayant mis trois cent mille personnes
sous la terre quad et à toute la
population s'est rassemblée population
syrienne qui a 10 ans avaient disparu
pour moi c'est gigantesque population de
jeu pas de la syrie c'est une guerre
civile qui était dans mon panier même
toutes les guerres civiles contemporaine
font beaucoup de morts regardez par
exemple la guerre civile américaine
elle a fait beaucoup plus de morts que
l'engagement américain dans la première
et dans la deuxième guerre mondiale et
donc les guerres civiles sont sons sont
très meurtrière mais c'est une guerre
civile
alors je ne dis pas que il faut s'en
réjouir puisque effectivement nous
n'avons pas nous réjouir des dictatures
on aimerait d'ailleurs qui est des
démocraties partout et lorient on a
laissé des régimes démocratiques dans 46
condamnait partir en syrie mais ç'a duré
trois ans jusqu'en 49 après il ya eu des
coups d'état militaires mais mais en
revanche sur le théâtre syrien
militairement
on avait certains avaient prévu une
déroute ne s'est pas de bachar assad et
même une déroute de
2 de la rue si elle n'a pas eu lieu il
ya eu des guerres n'est ce pas ou la
russie n'a pas réussi à maintenir le
gouvernement qu'elle avait soutenu je
veux parler je veux parler non je veux
parler en afghanistan l'afghanistan où
le gouvernement soutenu par les russes
qui ont fait été moins soutenue en 1992
a été remplacé par un gouvernement
debout jay dean qui a été encore pire
d'ailleurs puisque les bulls se sont
fermées ce qui est pire que la dictature
il ya la guerre civile
mais mais mais mais kutina quand même
mais poutine a quand même là vous pouvez
pas dire qu'il n'a pas il a maintenu la
guerre militairement est ce qu'une
victoire militaire ça c'est le bonheur
des gens n'ont pas eu droit à un mode
conclut de 2,2 mot de conclusion et des
enseignants un il ya un autre perdant
que la démocratie font la diplomatie
française et la diplomatie américaine
qui est quand même été tellement absents
je rappelle que barack obama à une prix
nobel de la paix pour n'avoir rien fait
dans les affaires internationales
pendant ses deux mandats et deuxième
point effectivement avant de commencer à
vous ses enseignes
effectivement comme à vannes avant rien
probablement mais deuxième point en
matière de relations internationales
effectivement les bons sentiments ça ne
marche pas et je crois que de ce point
de vue on a déjà parlé ici
emmanuel macron h1 opère un changement
qui est plutôt salutaire et bien
semble-t-il ya consensus sur ces types
là toi sur cette dernière réflexion
merci à tous les quatre restez connectés
dans un instant vous retrouverez un
focus consacré à patrick drahi le patron
d'alti cdc fer qui traverse une tempête
boursière sans précédent avec l'analyse
des lapins baron qui est journaliste du
figaro spécialisée dans ce sujet qui
vient de sortir un livre consacré à
patrick drahi merci à tous les quatre
bonsoir
[Musique]